hey what's up guys and welcome to
seoul's news for the 27th of august
finally enough noteworthy topics have
built up to the point where it's
actually worth it for me to make a video
about them so I'll keep you up to date
on everything you might have missed in
this video we talked about the recently
announced public beta version of Dark
Souls 2 that will be playable for ps3
owners I'll tell you the important bits
about the short multiplayer clip that
was revealed in an interview with the
director and towards the end of the
video we'll say our farewells to games
for Windows Live which has recently been
given a death sentence so let's get into
it
Dark Souls 2 is coming out in March and
this doesn't seem to be getting any
closer it's a long time away but there's
good news if you own a ps3 that is ps3
owners will be able to opt in to a beta
through PSN which will begin on October
5th in North America and Europe details
for how to register for the Dark Souls 2
beta will be shared through the official
Dark Souls Facebook page starting on
September 5th so if you own a ps3 like
the Dark Souls Facebook page and tune in
first thing on September 5th to opt into
the beta a month later in October you'll
hopefully be accepted and you'll be able
to test a portion of Dark Souls 2 to my
knowledge this is so that from software
can test their network service the
Facebook page is in the description and
as soon as more details become available
I'll put them in the description I'll
put them in annotations and stuff like
that furthermore and just follow me on
Twitter if you don't want to miss any
news or tweet about anything significant
obviously if you don't have a ps3 this
is bad news it would be great to play
the beta considering how long it's gonna
take to come out and it's something to
tide us over you may be reluctant to buy
a ps3 at this stage since the ps4 is
coming out so soon but is there honestly
any better time to switch consoles or
buy a console ps3 has some of the best
exclusives like journey Red Dead
Redemption and most importantly Demon
Souls if you like Dark Souls you'll love
Demon Souls and I'm starting a demon
Souls lore series so hey I think you
should buy a ps3 anyway so what will
this beta include this clip that I'm
playing right now should give you some
idea apparently the beta will feature
the most treacherous areas of Dark Souls
2 which will test your will to survive
apart from these quotes Namco Bandai
didn't provide any more specifics so
I'll take this to mean that there will
be some PvE
elements as well in an area that
encourages you to summon and invade so
maybe playing a strip of the game up
until a boss fight or something like
that
the only other noteworthy things I could
find within the clip are the following
summon phantoms now have our health are
incorporated into the UI PvP pacing
seems pretty much the same as Dark Souls
although you can't really get a feel for
it in the two seconds of PvP either you
see and the humanity counter still
hasn't returned
that's the little circle in the top left
and it's been consistently replaced with
a different image every clip we see so I
don't really see any point reading into
it at this stage the clip is a part of
an entire interview with the director
but he doesn't really say anything we
haven't heard before I think he's still
trying to convince you all that the
game's going to be just as difficult so
that pretty much sums up the beta news
if you don't own a ps3 and you're not
going to buy one then I'll try get into
the beta and I'll try show you
everything I can so onto the next topic
a little while ago Microsoft announced
that they were going to get rid of the
games for Windows Live Marketplace if
you don't know games for Windows Live is
the shitty service the Dark Souls PC
online runs off so by getting rid of the
marketplace this meant that you couldn't
purchase Dark Souls off the marketplace
this isn't a problem since retail
versions exist predictably shortly after
Microsoft announced they were going to
close the marketplace they announced
that they were going to shut down the
service as a whole and this is a problem
on July 1st 2014 Dark Souls PC online
will not run off games for Windows Live
for an online version to exist from
software we'll need to patch the games
online over to a new service so here's
where things start to get strange since
shortly after this was announced there
was a Facebook post supposedly from the
official Dark Souls Facebook page
floating around it said that Fromme
would patch the game over the Steamworks
which has valves online service the
internet rejoiced however the original
post was nowhere to be found on the
Facebook page
so was it a Photoshop it's hard to know
because Microsoft took down all their
posts about games Windows Live going
offline too which means that the
original Facebook post could have been
taken down because Microsoft changed
their mind about announcing the games
for Windows Live was going down
I hope that makes sense at any rate as
soon as I find out what's happening to
Dark Souls PC online I'll put an
annotation on the screen and I'll keep
you updated thanks for watching feel
free to like and spread the news also as
of today I'm starting a Demon Souls law
series so click here to check it out and
I'm also not stopping my Dark Souls lore
series so relax I'm not gonna stop that
so feel free to check out that series as
well and that's it later guys